eine corona notbremse für das ganze land
der bundestag stimmt dem neuen gesetz zu
protestdemo dagegen löst die polizei auf
schuldig in allen punkten
der ex-polizist der iec owen hat george
freund getötet das urteil gegen ihn
würden nicht nur schwarze bürgerrechtler
als meilenstein ein traditionsklub am
tiefpunkt schon jetzt steht schalke 04
als absteiger fest muss zum vierten mal
in seiner geschichte in die zweite liga
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers guten abend in allen
willkommen bei uns um 7 christian otto
mit dem sport ist natürlich auch mit
dabei und vielen emotionen im fußball
gelernt
ausgangs beschränkungen in vielen teilen
deutschlands rücken näher
der bundestag hat heute grünes licht
gegeben für eine corona notbremse die
dann im ganzen land und für alle
gleichermaßen gilt überall dort wo die
inzidenz über 100 liegt sie ist teil von
umstrittenen änderungen im
infektionsschutzgesetz was da genau
geplant ist und ab wann das gilt damit
beginnen wir heute abend und das erklärt
volker dutschek viel diskutiert die
ausgangs beschränkung jetzt von 22 bis 5
uhr
hier hat der gesetzgeber im vergleich
zum ersten entwurf gelockert bis
mitternacht darf zudem jeder allein
spazieren gehen und joggen in den
schulen ist wechsel unter richter beim
wert von 100 vorgeschrieben test pflicht
für alle schülerinnen und schüler
zweimal die woche
wenn er sieben tage wert über 165 steigt
gibt es nur noch distanz unterricht die
länder können notbetreuung auch in den
kitas anbieten
bei einer inzidenz bis 150 ist der
besuch der einzelhandelsgeschäfte nach
vorheriger termin buchungen möglich
voraussetzung ein negativer corona test
ab 150 ist nur noch das abholen von
bestellten waren möglichst außenbereiche
von zoos und botanischen gärten dürfen
besucher rein lassen allerdings nur mit
negativen corona test kontaktloser sport
geht aber nur mit maximal zwei leuten
beziehungsweise den angehörigen des
eigenen haushaltes ausnahme sportler
innen unter 14 jahre dürfen maximal zu
fünf trainieren
bei den home office bestimmungen hat der
gesetzgeber nachgeschärft falls möglich
muss der arbeitgeber seinen angestellten
home office ermöglichen und arbeitnehmer
müssen das normalerweise auch annehmen
ablehnungsgründe können die störung
durch dritte oder ein fehlender
adäquater arbeitsplatz im home-office
seien beschäftigte die nicht im home
office arbeiten sollen von ihrem
arbeitgeber künftig zwei corona tests
pro woche angeboten bekommen das wurde
leidenschaftlich gerungen heute in
berlin im bundestag war die regierung
eindringlich für das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz die opposition
hatte massive einwände
draußen gab es rangeleien mit
demonstranten über den tag im und vor
dem parlament lasst bohnsack draußen auf
den straßen berlins sind es ein paar
tausend die gegen das
infektionsschutzgesetz demonstieren
abstände werden nicht eingehalten masken
nicht getragen die polizei löste die
veranstaltung auf drinnen im bundestag
ist es an der regierung die geplante
corona notbremse zu verteidigen
das sind verstehe ich die logik nicht
dass einige immer warten wollen bis die
intensivstation überfüllt sind bevor sie
maßnahmen machen wenn wir leid vermeiden
können sollten wir es vermeiden
rechtzeitig und infektion erst gar nicht
entstehen lassen
das was wir jetzt brauchen ist klarheit
und konsequenz was ist wenn die inzidenz
werte wenn die infektionszahlen zu sehr
steigen und wir sagen wenn sie über 100
gehen dann muss etwas getan werden und
das gehört zu klarheit und konsequenz
dazu über in deutschland und auch immer
und in jedem fall kritik am
gesetzentwurf kommt von allen
oppositionsparteien wenn auch aus
unterschiedlichen gründen zu beanstanden
die grünen mangelnde stringenz wir haben
eine 35er incidents hunderter von
incidents 165 er incidents und 150 er
ins ident das versteht kein mensch hfg
und fdp lehnen vor allem die
ausgangssperren ab die liberalen
kündigen gar den gang zum
verfassungsgericht an
es gibt keine wissenschaftliche evidenz
die belegt dass ausgangssperren die
verbreitung des virus verhindern allein
darauf zu hoffen dass es etwas bringt
reicht eben nicht aus um einen so
schwerwiegenden grundrechtseingriff zu
rechtfertigen impfstoff zu beschaffen wo
immer es welchen zu beschaffen gibt
wollen sie das erste mal in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik die
freiheitsrechte des grundgesetzes
einschränken
bereits morgen will sich der bundesrat
in einer sondersitzung mit den
gesetzesänderungen befassen
und dann gucken wir jetzt auf die
aktuellen corona zahlen innerhalb von 24
stunden registrierte das
robert-koch-institut 24 1884
neuinfektionen das sind 3191 mehr als
vergangenen mittwoch 331 menschen
starben in verbindung mit dem virus
die sieben tage instituts liegt
bundesweit bei 160,1 eine andere
wichtige zahl 750 milliarden euro mit
dieser summe will die eu ihren
mitgliedsstaaten helfen nach der
pandemie wieder auf die beine zu kommen
und deutschland steht dem jetzt nicht
mehr im weg das bundesverfassungsgericht
hat einen eilantrag gegen die
gemeinschaftliche verschuldung
abgewiesen
das heißt der bundespräsident kann das
zustimmungsgesetz jetzt erstmal
unterzeichnen
eine genaue prüfung in der sache kommt
aber noch unser nächstes thema heute
abend mehr gerechtigkeit für alle us
bürger im alltag das sind die großen
hoffnungen verbunden sind mit dem
schuldspruch gegen den früheren
polizisten devon in minneapolis ein
weißer beamter wird zur rechenschaft
gezogen wegen totschlags an einem
schwarzen mitbürger die welt schaut zu
steht heute auf einem plakat der
demonstranten in minneapolis und in der
tat hatte der tod von george floyd
massenproteste ausgelöst gegen
polizeigewalt und rassismus nach diesem
tag im vergangenen mai neun minuten lang
drückt der polizist sein knie auf den
hals von george freut der um sein leben
gefleht und wenig später stirbt aus den
usa an at wissen dieses bild steht für
ein stück hoffnung ein weißer ex
polizist in handschellen zur
rechenschaft gezogen für die tötung
eines schwarzen zuvor hatte der richter
das urteil verlesen schuldig ein
unbewegter directshow in dem für noch
zweiten grades ohne tötungsvorsatz und
für zwei weitere punkte bis zu 40 jahre
haft
gerechtigkeit rufen sie weil die
verteidigung keine zweifel wecken konnte
bei den zwölf geschworenen
für sie ist es auch ein urteil über den
systemischen rassismus in amerika
deutschland konnte nicht mehr atmen wir
können zum ersten mal ein wenig aufatmen
viele sind überzeugt dass es ohne das
video von george hotz tod die neun
minuten 29 sekunden nicht zu einer
verurteilung gekommen wäre platz familie
feiert den schuldspruch als historisch
will weiter druck machen auf die politik
ich werde jeden tag weiter kämpfen der
nicht kämpfen nicht nur für george
sondern für jeden auf dieser erde
die familie bekam einen anruf von us
präsident joe biden und vize-präsidentin
kamen beide versprechen eine landesweite
polizeireform voranzutreiben
die tief sitzende angst und das traum
war der schmerz die erschöpfung die
schwarze und braune amerikaner jeden tag
erfahren wir dürfen wir können nicht weg
schau wir haben eine chance die richtung
zu ändern
in diesem land nicht nur in minneapolis
auch in vielen anderen städten feiern
sie weil dieses urteil hoffnung macht
beginn live nach minneapolis zu benjamin
daniel namen benjamín es gab ja immer
mal ein bisschen hoffnung dass
systematische polizei gewalt und
rassismus in den usa konsequent verfolgt
würden es gab dann aber vor allem viele
enttäuschungen ist denn jetzt mehr grund
dazu glauben dass sich was ändert
das würde ich mit einem ich sag mal
klein geschriebenen jahr beantworten das
urteil hat natürlich viel positive
energie und hoffnung freigesetzt aber
man darf jetzt natürlich auch nicht den
fehler zu machen es überzubewerten
es geht hier schließlich um eine
erbsünde amerikas der coach freut hat
nie verheilte wunden noch weiter
aufgerissen also in der gesamtschau ist
es ein doch eher kleiner schritt im
kampf amerikas gegen systemische gewalt
polizei gegen systemischen rassismus und
polizeigewalt
es ist aber gleichwohl bemerkenswert
dass sich joe biden der us-präsident
bereits vor der verkündung des urteils
also zum laufenden prozess ja geäußert
hat und damit auch gewissermaßen
positioniert hat das ist ungewöhnlich
und auch seine worte und die worte der
vize-präsidentin nach der
urteilsverkündung die waren doch sehr
klar und deutlich damit haben sie diese
wichtigen themen ganz oben auf ihre
agenda gehoben und sie werden sich dann
auch sicher daran messen lassen müssen
inwiefern sie den wandel einen echten
wandel in der amerikanischen
gesellschaft in diesen zwei ja so
wichtigen punkten haben voranbringen
können wenn ihr mann daniel live heute
abend vielen dank und jetzt in der
sendung der klimaschutz bis zum jahr
2050 will die eu klimaneutral sein
ein ehrgeiziges ziel und um das zu
erreichen haben die mitgliedsstaaten und
das europaparlament ihr mittelfristiges
klimaziel jetzt verschärft das ergebnis
bis 2030 soll der co2 ausstoß um 55
prozent gesenkt werden im vergleich zu
allerdings hat die eu bis vergangenes
jahr ihren co2 ausstoß gerade mal um
rund 25 prozent reduziert für die
restlichen 30 prozent bleiben also nicht
einmal zehn jahre wie das gelingen soll
von palo eine zukunft mit deutlich
weniger treibhausgasen
dafür will die eu eine ganze menge der
klimakiller einsparen mehr als eine
milliarde tonnen schon bis 2030
das ist sehr sehr ambitioniert und wir
werden das nur schaffen wenn sich alle
beteiligten jetzt anstrengen und wenn es
ganz klar jetzt ein klimaschutz turbo in
ganz europa gibt von tricks reden
vertreter der grünen und umweltschützern
denn auch kohlendioxid das in wäldern
gespart
der wirt soll eingerechnet werden bis zu
225 millionen tonnen durch aufforstung
sollen es 300 millionen werden die
kritik daran mit dürren wo uns die
wälder wegsterben wo die wälder er zu
emissionsquellen werden als dass sie
wirklich co2 binden haben wir wirkliche
co2 minderung weniger kohle weniger co2
von autos energieeffizienz oder haben
wir rechentricks ob beim hausbau im
straßenverkehr alle werden sich
umstellen müssen bürgerinnen bürger die
ganze wirtschaft muss sich neu
ausrichten
wir sehen zum beispiel die
chemieindustrie die sich stark umstellen
muss die einen enormen bedarf an
erneuerbaren sauberen und günstigen
strom haben wird also durchaus risiken
mit dabei auch arbeitsplätze mit dabei
aber natürlich auch sonst im
klimaneutral und wettbewerbsfähigen
orangen wie alles konkret gehen soll
will die eu im juli vorstellen fit for
50 5 heißt ihr gesetzgebungs paket fit
für 55 es wird um im sportlichen bild zu
bleiben ein sehr ehrgeiziges
trainingsziel wohin steuert russland
welchen zweck haben die russischen
truppen aufmärsche an der grenze zur
ukraine
wie geht es weiter mit dem schwerkranken
kreml-kritiker alexej nawalny viele
drängende fragen eine gelegenheit für
antworten ließ wladimir putin heute
verstreichen
epochal inszeniert sprach der russische
präsident bei seiner traditionellen rede
an die nation viel über die korona
pandemie außerdem schickte er ein signal
an den westen putin warnte vor dem
überschreiten roter linien aus moskau
christiansen gleich drei pcr tests
mussten die gäste vorweisen um dabei zu
sein bei wladimir putins rede an die
nation
und eigentlich herr springe masken
pflicht im saal
in der realität sieht es dann aber so
aus und das obwohl putin den beginn
seiner rede den schwierigen kampf gegen
die pandemie widmet und appelliert an
die im skeptischen russinnen und russen
bitte ich wende mich noch einmal an alle
bürger russlands mit dem auge lassen
wie sich impfen nur so blockieren wir
die lebensgefährliche epidemie einen
anderen weg gibt es muss er heute auf
neue erkenntnisse zu themen wie dem
ukraine konflikt oder zur situation von
kreml kritiker navalny gewartet hatte
wurde enttäuscht kein wort dazu
putins auftritt heute vor allem nach
innen gerichtet er versprach finanzielle
hilfe für familien in russland und dann
doch eine vage warnung an den westen
ich hoffe dass niemandem in den sinn
kommt die sogenannte rote linie in den
beziehungen zu russland zu überschreiten
und wo sie verlaufen wird das werden wir
in jedem konkreten fall selbst bestimmen
wo diese rote linie in russland liegt
zeigte kreml schon vor der rede
bei russland weiten protesten für
navalny gab es bis zum abend rund 300
festnahmen und in moskau wird einmal
mehr die navalny vertraute lubov sowohl
festgenommen ich wurde festgenommen nur
für den gedanken an der demo
teilzunehmen
vor einer stunde hat in moskau die nicht
genehmigte solidaritäts demo für alexej
nawalny begonnen wladimir putin muss die
aufmerksamkeit heute teilen mit
tausenden gegnern seiner politik
zurück nach deutschland verbrechen im
namen der terror miliz es dafür ist
jetzt eine leverkusenerin verurteilt
worden und zwar zu vier jahren und drei
monaten haft unter anderem wegen
beihilfe zu verbrechen gegen die
menschlichkeit die inzwischen 35-jährige
war 2015 mit ihrer kleinen tochter nach
syrien ausgereist und hatte dort einen
es terroristen geheiratet
in ihrem haushalt wie sie eine farce
klaffte je sident für sich arbeiten
die anklage lastete ihr an dass sie vor
gericht keine reue gezeigt habe und
jetzt nochmal zum kampf gegen die
pandemie die offizielle deutsche corona
waren app ist jetzt aktualisiert worden
ihre bilanz bisher ist eher gemischt 27
millionen mal wurde die app installiert
insgesamt etwa 376.000 nutzer meldeten
ihr positives testergebnis zur
nachverfolgung das sind täglich im
schnitt rund 3700 für mehr sicherheit
bei kontakten in innenräumen soll jetzt
eine neue funktion sorgen die app
erstellt jetzt auch sogenannte qr-codes
digitale eintrittskarten für öffentliche
und private veranstaltungen sven regn
hat mehr darauf mussten die nutzer der
korona war fast ein jahr warten endlich
kann sie solche qr codes lesen und damit
einchecken spricht die app merkt sich
wann man das café das kaufhaus oder die
private feier besucht diese daten landen
im tagebuch der app und zwar nur auf dem
eigenen telefon
man benötigt der heute überhaupt gar
keine kontaktdaten von nutzern einer
veranstaltung um diese zu informieren
dass sie einem erhöhten corona risiko
ausgesetzt waren
das ganze kann man heute anonym und
dezentral gestalten die gesundheitsämter
bleiben deshalb nach wie vor außen vor
denn auch die version 2.0 der vanek
bleibt dem ursprünglichen ansatz treu
nur die app nutzer innen entscheiden was
passiert wenn die bahn app warnt andere
anbieter wie etwa die loop erfassen
dagegen zentral ort und zeit eines
einkaufs
diese daten werden auf einem großen
server gespeichert auf denen auch die
gesundheitsämter zugreifen können immer
mehr bundesländer greifen zu dieser
zentralen lösung
es ist natürlich wichtig dass wir
künftig zu einer situation kommen wo
nicht nur die lukb die eintrittskarte
für die öffentlichkeit ist sondern eben
auch andere möglichkeiten in erwägung
gezogen werden andere apps aber
natürlich auch die papierene variante
immerhin die qr-codes beider apps
passend zusammen man muss also nicht
zweimal scannen die korona vanek bekommt
ende des monats zudem eine test nachweis
funktion
außerdem soll der digitale impfpass ab
juni dort abrufbar sein
der dornröschenschlaf der app ist also
anscheinend vorbei der schauspieler und
synchronsprecher thomas fritsch ist tot
mit drei sind einer zuviel wurde er den
70er jahren zu einem der beliebtesten
fernseh schauspieler
es sollten serien wie rivalen der
rennbahn und die rosenheim cops als
synchronsprecher lieh fritsch seine
stimme an stars wie russell crowe marlon
brando und jeff bridges thomas fritsch
wurde 77 jahre alt
eine 60 jahre umfassende karriere bei
film fernsehen und bühne und der
liebhaber ist ja eigentlich der
langweiligste die langweiligste rolle
von allen hat fritz mal gesagt der
bösewicht und der komiker machen spaß
guter satz
bei mir wird nicht so spaßig ganz im
gegenteil zum vierten mal in der
vereinsgeschichte muss schalke 04 den
abstieg verkraften und nach 33 jahren
hinab in die zweite liga weiterer
tiefpunkt nach dem 0 1 in bielefeld
gewaltbereite fans die voller wut die
königsblauen am eigenen stadion
attackierten die polizei hat massive
aggressionen gegen die mannschaft nach
der rückkehr aus bielefeld bestätigt der
verein sah die unversehrtheit der
spieler gefährdet
auf dem feld war das team zuvor dem
abstieg nicht entkommen
nach 21 niederlagen und nur 13 punkten
kein wunder mehr die fünfzigste minute
bringt bielefeld das entscheidende 1 0
durch fabian klos das 76 alter gegentor
nur 18 mal in 30 spielen traf königsblau
nach gelb rot für malik ist am ende
nichts mehr zu machen bielefeld sichert
wichtige punkte im abstiegskampf den
schalke verliert fünf trainer konnten
schalten niederlage der saison nicht
verhindern
mehr als 200 millionen euro schulden
haben sich zudem über die jahre
angehäuft kaum licht in sicht am ende
des tunnels der aufschrei war enorm die
sorge groß nun ist nach zwei brisanten
tagen die gründung der super league als
konkurrenz zur champions league vom
tisch nach heftigen protesten erklärten
zu ersten sechs englische klubs ihren
rückzug der anfang vom ende chelsea fans
feiern von stadion ihr klub sie zurück
wie ein kartenhaus zerfällt danach die
super league in der europas reichste
verein unter sich bleiben wollten um
mehr geld zu verdienen müssen die nacht
folgen alle englischen clubs ich war in
münchen als chelsea die champions league
gewonnen hat dass sie es besser
ich bin so glücklich wir haben die
premier league den englischen fussball
gerettet wir das ist eine einheitsfront
aus fans spielern trainern und der
politik premier johnson drohte gar mit
einer gesetzgebungs bombe
nun müssen milliardenschwere
club-eigentümer aus aller welt
öffentlich zu kreuze kriechen
ich möchte mich bei allen fans des
liverpool fußballclubs entschuldigen für
die spaltung die ich vorangetrieben habe
ich muss mich bei jürgen klopp den
spielern und allen entschuldigen die so
hart arbeiten um unsere fans stolz zu
machen
jahrelang in hinterzimmern geplant geht
der elite-liga nach 48 stunden die puste
aus weitere vereine wollen nicht mehr
der hauptinitiator gibt das spiel
verloren vorerst bleibe von der
schönheit des projekts überzeugt das ist
das traditionelle ligasystem aufgewertet
hätte aber nein das projekt das den
besten wettbewerb der welt begründet
hätte liegt auf eis zwölf top klubs
wollten die ohnehin heikle balance
zwischen fan kultur und kommerz noch
stärker strapazieren und gehen als
verlierer allein vom platz geld ist doch
nicht alles wichtig
vielen dank christian heute ist der 95
geburtstag von königin elizabeth der
zweite ihr erster seit mehr als 70
jahren ohne prinz philip an ihrer seite
es ist ein stiller geburtstag der palast
veröffentlicht heute nur dieses archiv
foto von ihr und eine botschaft an ihr
volk in dem sich elisabeth für die
vielen geburtstagswünsche bedankt und
gleichzeitig für die große anteilnahme
nach philips tot
die dankbarkeit einer trauernden
monarchen wie immer mittwochs haben
jetzt noch die lottozahlen für sie und
die lauten 1 18 24 27 37 47 die
superzahl 0 weitere gewinnzahlen im zdf
text und auf lotto zdf de das wetter ab
morgen kühl aber dafür meist trocken ist
anthony hat gleich mehr im heute-journal
freut sich der kollege claus kleber auf
sie um 21.45 und damit danke für heute
gern bis morgen aber erst hinein einen
angenehmen abend
[Musik]